hello and welcome to New World review
your source for everything dark and
twisted deep in the souls of manga
writers and animators but also fluffy
light bunny rabbits
sometimes those bunny rabbits will be
dark and twisted and may try to eat your
soul but before they do they'll make you
Savior so you kind of feel okay before
they eat your soul hi it's me Grand Line
waifu and it's time for episodes 8 and 9
of exam reading signs before we get
started as always majority rules so let
me know if you're enjoying this by
tippet a pin that like button if you
don't like it and want your soul back
tap that dislike button no souls will be
refunded if there are particular themes
or ideas you want me to address as I
review the episodes let me know in the
comments now on to the video
oh warning spoilers beep boop boop boop
beep
spoilers episode 8 the stars have quite
a delicious psychological jaunt actually
one that showed its hand early but will
have a lot of new implications I think
so let's get into that majority rules is
a great way to mess with people's heads
we see it in many political systems
around the world no one has to tell
anyone how they will vote but since they
know that majority rules why don't they
just discuss decisions before tapping
them into their watches it would seem a
very simple way of being sure that
they're making consistently helpful
decisions then again maybe that would
make the process too obvious or the link
to real world politics too strong since
hunter Hunter was written in 1998 it's
got a beautiful relevance now and I'm
glad I'm watching this as an adult with
all the political knowledge I have now I
think I'd have missed out on those
details if I'd seen this as a 7 or 8
year old it would have been great to see
them discuss their options and then make
a different choice it's something that
keeps switching in this series the
extent to which we as an audience get
given information the main characters
don't in this case it seems they want us
to be in lis oreos frustration though
when he gets overexcited it's hard to
actually connect with so if that's the
reason it's not a good enough one
especially since we hear God's confused
response that lis Oreo doesn't
suggesting the results are being altered
from the start I'd have liked a little
more clarity around that moment but that
entirely depends on whether they're
trying to trick the audience along with
the main character or if it's just poor
storytelling speaking of tricking an
audience Tonpa he's in the spotlight
again but I don't know whether he's as
captivating as the reactions of those
around him
there's nothing less interesting to me
than someone who is cruel because it's
fun and while I'm sure there is more
to Tonpa than that i have yet to see it
anytime he's been involved he's either
done something incredibly childish
himself or been sniggered about by the
others at time of writing I haven't seen
episode 9 so it's entirely possible that
he'll redeem himself but I highly doubt
it I think the most embarrassing thing
for him at this point and the most
satisfying thing for us watching would
be for him to be made a hunter so that
he can't take the exam anymore it would
just be enjoyable to watch his reaction
to something he can't control like that
take away his fun and see what happens
meanwhile I'm surprised that no one
Kiowa specifically threw him off the
edge I guess it's hard to play majority
rules without a tiebreaker but still it
would be the easiest way to do things
I was also engrossed in his little
powering up moment with that mercenary
with a 200 year life sentence the fact
that tompas art was drawn the same with
the same intensity of color suggests
that he has potentially got the strength
to defeat the mercenary and chose not to
the rhythmic undertone to the moment
building up to the undercut of his
action was nicely played I think either
way in that moment I would have been
surprised either if he'd done something
and proven himself or not done something
and shown his hand he's been quiet for a
few episodes but the fact that he's
reached this far suggests he's more
powerful and intelligent than he appears
after all there are only 39 of the 405
entrants left which means he must have
done something right especially since he
works alone or works purely on stealing
the wind from people at the end which is
remarkably energy draining even if he
just waits to see how others do
something to copy it that takes a level
of tenacious not many have I know I
don't
that sounds tiring you know I do wonder
where that on post been hired as a
destroyer of worlds sort of overlord
examiner whose job is purely to weed out
the weaklings who can't deal with him I
guess I'm a little more involved in his
narrative than I let on I think on that
point I need to clarify something
because it's only fair when I complain
about the world of hunter hunter it's
often only looking at the setting really
I should be looking at the composition
of the people involved in the world too
because they are the world in a very
real sense the backdrop for this episode
was and probably will be for episode 9
about being in a maze and using the
abilities of these three-dimensional
characters to stumble their way through
it on top of that the bland setting is
further detailed with the personalities
of the examiners and the tools they use
to create their phase for every step of
this exam the tall
become more colorful and characterful in
a way that is itself world building
we've gone from stamina itself being the
world building tool to imprisoned humans
each I'd imagine with their own stories
for example why was the mercenary so
okay with not fighting how often do
exams come through here how else are
they supposed to reduce their sentences
because I thought the exam changed every
year is he really okay with not getting
the chance to reduce his sentence even
further how does one become so
laissez-faire about that situation I
suppose that when you have 199 years
left on the clock you may as well relax
in any case these characters the ones
that drift in and out of the mains lives
they count as world building tools too
they're all set dressing as opposed to
undermine their worth and reduce them to
a simple couple of words this examiner
is also technically a set dressing at
this point and possibly forever
considering the treatment mentioned
bahara got the definition of a hunter
keeps getting broadened I'm assuming
this hunter hunts and collects people
which to me seems like a very loud call
on the ethical standing of hunters the
world we're in is one that officially
imprisons people who have done awful
things and allows examiner's to use them
as testing materials and examiner's we
know and knew that they were okay with
examinees dying but this is another
thing it's testing them against
criminals which is itself fascinating
for a reason I can't quite put my finger
on something to do with the kind of
world that allows this behavior being
the sort of world that also creates gone
Kiowa and karateka I'm somewhat
surprised that they Oreo and Cora pika
to a great extent I suppose we're at all
surprised that the world treated them
the way it did it also explains a little
of Kilwa and guns acceptance and
sociopathy the world is a horrible harsh
unforgiving place karappa car has the
right idea
revenge seems as though it will be the
best way to deal with the world as it
exists the audios beautiful idealism I
now expect to be harshly and with great
finality crushed by this world yay onto
episode nine karateka hello it's been a
while it's like your dormant and boring
until your special moments and you pick
your moments very carefully as gone said
in a way that made me laugh so hard Liam
asked why I was laughing in another room
maybe we should keep karappa Karam
spiders as an arachnophobia I would
appreciate karateka around to deal with
the spiders that turn up around
and in my house but we'll ignore that
for now having just said that the world
is made more colorful by those that
inhabit it I was highly amused by the
way they decided to animate Majid
Annie's powerup it comes under the same
category as telling us the crimes and
names of the prisoners while the actual
main characters are left in the dark and
letting us hear God's confusion at the
audio assuming their majority rules
responses were the same as an audience
we get information that the main
characters don't specifically and that
puts us on the outside and allows us to
make solid guesses about what will come
next with greater or lesser degrees of
satisfaction for example I knew as soon
as the candle came out that there would
be something to do with explosives in it
because the prisoner was a serial bomber
I don't know whether it's to make us
feel as though we're more intelligent
than the main character and flag the
situation or an oversight but the big
sign saying watch out this guy can kill
you without touching you is a big one we
also got a clue in episode 8 about what
the aura what the energy of a powerful
individual looks and feels like so when
we came to this moment in episode 9 it
was just embarrassing from outside and
it was supposed to be this episode was a
carefully crafted and balanced mix of
seriousness and fast that on the whole I
quite enjoyed the fast of the
Frankenstein majid Jaime the switcheroo
candles gone simple response to a simple
problem was backed up with the
seriousness in the choosing of a candle
the inescapability of the decisions they
have to make as a team in this phase and
the reaction karateka had from the start
we were set up to find Majid Ani
unimpressive and they did that
incredibly well we knew that could
happen who couldn't fight someone of
that size without his weapons and that
was made very clear in the physical
angle of frames which emphasized his
length but not his strength the white of
his clothes and the softness of his
lines made him look weaker still which
helped to build to the climax of the
episode the point they wanted to drive
home was careful foreshadowing that this
would not be outright fighting but we
were told that karapa ker wouldn't mind
trying cute little Majid Annie's fatal
flaw was not being able to read his
opponent kadar Biko was never afraid or
at least he didn't seem it he was
prepared to do his best and I think that
readiness is constant karateka however
the moment his eyes turned red things
became exciting the second that spider
appeared we got a stringed refrain that
connected us immediately to korabik and
his thoughts we were reminded of the
importance of it to Arabica and
interestingly we were given the
silhouette
of those here searching for the reason I
say interesting is that in that moment
because I went back and checked in that
moment the silhouettes we were given did
not include the pitiful Majid Ani
the time stamp is 1708 in case you'd
like to take a look
I suspect that time stamp will become
very important to me for an entire arc
eventually unless they show it several
times what I want to know is whether
Majid Ani is dead if he isn't karapa cat
talking to him makes sense if he's dead
who is koppikhar talking to and he says
he will kill them for speaking of the
Phantom troupe the other prisoners the
hunter running the phase or his own team
who is cut up occur in that moment all
you'd have to do in theory is walk up to
him and say phantom troupe and he'll
punch your lights out it's pretty insane
that up to now we haven't seen any
spiders at all when we do though we'll
know how to identify true members we
have learned from our poor sad
unconscious possibly dead friend
Majid Ani a moment silence for Majid Ani
place while I'm prepared to see what lay
Oreo has for us next episode I'm also
expecting he's going to fail immediately
and Kilwa will save the day somehow but
that's just a random off-the-wall guess
and that's all you're gonna get from me
if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produces in general
please do consider donating to the new
world review patreon because the support
of all you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
if patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support the channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun then
please do head over to the discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
re takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on episodes 8 and 9 of Hunter
hunter this has been the New World
review and I'll see you next time
[Music]